quatre bras - feedback I'm a police
officer of the law
let's find some baddies I'm ready to
bust some speedy burn star Canyon sign I
love being a cop what I'm gonna have to
give this guy a ticket excuse me sir
you're not even holding the whales come
on and step out of the vehicle sir
don't make me shoot you not even a
flinch how the [ __ ] am i holding this oh
[ __ ] sorry stupid people in this game
what are they doing I love being a cop
fly oh no Jesus oh my god I think we
found a prostitute we better arrest look
how she walks only prostitutes walks
like that everyone knows that now what
are you looking at huh
what are you looking at sir that's right
[ __ ] ah
don't resist I'm an officer of the law
don't resist a steady follow with me
rectangle tits don't resist don't resist
I'm an officer of the law
Oh God wait a sec [ __ ] don't resist
don't resist don't resist this is
probably my favorite game ever I'm not
even kidding I'm an officer of the law
what how did he do that he's resisting
take him out
what are you looking at I'm the best cop
in the world I'm the best cop in the
world what happen you kidding me
I love being a cop I love being a cop
it's my favorite job I love being a cop
oh you're lucky you get out of this one
quick huh force entry about police step
aside
someone breaking this out someone broke
in this house
it looks like my job is well done better
call for an ambulance we have a report
that someone has broken into a building
there could be a thief oh god it's the
same building she cloned herself LAPD
I'm a cop
what's going on here there's nothing
wrong here there's so much wrong here
what are you talking about don't resist
god I love being a cop
oh Jesus what happened what the [ __ ]
just happened what the [ __ ] are you
doing I got us the ticket you so you
drunk he's not drunk well what kind of
drugs are you on man Jesus Christ really
[ __ ] really MVPD stop the vehicle
she's running son of a [ __ ] is
resisting for real this time
what's she doing with an umbrella she's
trying to play it off for some [ __ ]
think I don't see you what the hell was
that umbrella trick all about get you
now criminal scum yeah hey I will wrist
it up
I will rested you now I can do whatever
I why oh god damn it all right get in
the car quick stop vibrating please what
are you doing stop stop that dancing now
damn it I don't have time for this uh-oh
she teleported of course of course
stop teleporting you're scaring the [ __ ]
out of me I put you in there
a possible criminal damn it
better break it in what's going on here
what's going on here huh aah it's got a
god aah
make sure he's dead piece of [ __ ] what a
[ __ ] idiot
almost died yeah you like it [ __ ] yeah
that's right
suck on those balls [ __ ] yeah yeah
what's up [ __ ] what's up oh she's
still vibrating huh wow what a great
show drug dealers my mom was killed by
drug dealers get in
I'm an office I get damn it my car broke
down what do I do
seriously are you [ __ ] kidding me
I better bring my sidekick miss vibrator
stop right there criminal scum [ __ ] I
press good I've done that episode there
if you enjoy watching go ahead and hit
that like button and I will see you
Bruce as always in the next one stay
awesome brauch